-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
Now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
After the White House
announced last week
that the construction
will resume on the border wall,
President Biden told reporters,
"I was told that
I had no choice."
Oh, man, I have a bad feeling
we're gonna find out
this was all the work of one
really good telemarketer.
[ As Biden ] They said
if I build a border wall,
I get three months
of Spectrum Internet.
I had to do it.
[ Normal voice ]
According to a new analysis,
over one-third
of Supreme Court decisions
are decided unanimously.
The other two-thirds are decided
by whoever took Clarence Thomas
on his last vacation.
[ Laughter ]
The IRS last week placed a lien
on a Florida property
owned by Rudy Giuliani.
I'm guessing
the Haunted Mansion?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ] It's all yours.
Those ghosts won't let me sleep.
[ Normal voice ]
After leaving the White House,
former president Trump
reportedly shared details
about the capabilities
of U.S. nuclear submarines
with an Australian billionaire,
including how close
they can sail to Russian vessels
without being detected.
Said Trump, "Oh, come on,
I'm not an idiot.
I told Putin first."
[ Laughter ]
House Republicans
reportedly held
a phones-off, closed-door
meeting today
to discuss the speakership.
And when they turned
their phones back on,
Matt Gaetz had
three more Venmo requests.
[ Laughter ]
New York governor Kathy Hochul
ordered
the State Liquor Authority
to allow bars to serve alcohol
as early as 8:00 a.m. yesterday
for the Buffalo Bills game
played in London.
Not only that,
during the Giants game,
she temporarily
legalized heroin.
[ Laughter ]
The genetic testing company
23andMe announced last week
that hackers stole personal
data from their database.
Authorities described
the suspect
as 62% European and 38%
East Asian and Native American.
[ Laughter ]
Georgia is said to become
the first state in the country
to offer medical marijuana
at pharmacies.
So you'll finally have a use
for that giant receipt.
[ Laughter ]
Burger King has announced
that it will offer a new side
that is half French fries,
half onion rings.
Wow, the only way
you could get that before
was to order onion rings.
[ Laughter ]
Best joke of the day.
It's a little bit --
Still a really good show,
but it's a little bit downhill
after the onion rings.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Google Cloud today
announced a new
artificial-intelligence-powered
search function for doctors,
because nothing inspires
confidence in your doctor
quite like hearing,
"Let's Google it."
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're off and running.
It is never easy to make
a transition like this.
But I do want to address --
I'm sure you all are aware
of the atrocities
that were committed
against Israel this weekend.
They were monstrous
and horrific acts of violence.
I will not pretend
to have any answers
as to how to respond
to a crisis like this.
I will only say
that in the moments
when we are confronted
with such evil, inhumane acts,
we are most at risk
of losing our own humanity.
When we are, justifiably,
blind with rage and sadness,
we can make choices
that will have massive,
irrevocable impacts on the lives
of our fellow man.
It requires
the absolute best of us
to think clearly
in times like this.
And I hope with all my heart
the best of us can emerge in
this time of unthinkable loss.
Thank you, everybody,
for bearing with me to say that.